well it's been about three and a half
years since Suicide Squad looking
forward to that comment section
seriously yeah birds of prey in the
fantabulous longest title ever since
don't be a menace to South Central while
drinking your juice in the hood so birds
of prey is a birds of prey it's not
really a birds of prey movie birds of
prey prequel it's generally a Harley
Quinn movie Harley and Joker they have
split Charlie's dealing with it because
it's not just like okay split done on to
other things now she's actually dealing
with it for the beginning of this movie
I appreciated that there are phases
before acceptance however there are a
few people in Gotham who are like you
mean that lady's been trolling us and
[ __ ] with us all those times she no
longer has the Joker back in her corner
I say we kill her the one who really
wants to do that as Romans Ionis I
always said sionis I guess it's Iona's
who is black mask played by Ewan
McGregor he does not like her at all so
he's coming after her there's a diamonds
that she needs to get for him to save
her life which sounds remarkably like
one of the plots of snatcher involving
brick top now that I'm thinking about it
and then you start meeting the birds of
prey okay what I liked about this movie
is Margot Robbie is Harley Quinn
whatever your grievances was Suicide
Squad she's fantastic
but she just completely sells it the
voice the persona when she's vulnerable
you feel for her when she's kicking ass
she is doing that quite efficiently and
all with the whimsical kind of fun you
would expect from Harley Quinn she was
great actually really likes canary as
well those were a great team up they
team up the earliest actually my one of
my favorites in the movie it's actually
Huntress and you don't get much of
Huntress however Huntress has the best
sounding arc so I'm like so as much as I
loved Huntress in the movie I felt
robbed it was like I want to see her
back story when you see flashbacks of
her backstory but I want to see the
whole movie you know be like Punisher
but with her which sounds amazing when
they just think about it so basically as
the band is slowly getting together they
get together in the last act and that's
when you really you really feel the
dynamic it's the vibe that Suicide Squad
was probably going for also the action
the fight sequences I thought they were
really exciting okay
my main grievance the thing I did wrong
is I didn't watch this movie I was high
I'm just saying this is the kind of
movie probably good I do probably
enhances the experience whatever it's
no one cares put your Dare shirt down
however the villain in this movie black
mask Roman Simon is played by Ewan
McGregor at first I was like he's having
fun with the role I'm liking this I was
really digging it but then the movie
just keeps going until I felt it went
too far in terms of just the cartoonish
nature of it not fun cartoonish nature
no when he was doing that I was having a
good time with it like the scene in the
trailer is like who's having a good time
however this is I mean it's
birds-of-prey is gonna be a girl-power
movie for sure how is it not gonna be
it's curtains birds-of-prey no question
about that but this movie does go to the
point where I feel like it draws a line
in the sand where it's like alright
women over there dudes over there good
people shitty people it's the theme of
the movie and they push it really far
with him he's a complete misogynistic
[ __ ] to the point where I'm like am I
even watched in black mask right now
like I have the finger on the pulse of
all the black mask story arcs but he
never got this from Black Mass I mean
you wouldn't McGregor acts to the [ __ ]
out of it I mean let's be real here he
does but his character still locked into
what I consider a one-dimensional box
because it's just who he is how the
movie portrays him and his motivation
he's a guy who wants to kill Harley
Quinn because well he's a really
misogynistic guy and she's a woman and
he hates her he's like one of the subway
[ __ ] in the Joker movie got his own
movie became the villain and now he's
even worse the best villains for me and
his personal tastes I totally get it but
the best villains for me are the ones
were when they tell the hero or the
audience their motivation there's an
argument to be made there it does make
you pause and go I see where you're
coming from still got a stop because
you're a maniac or at the very least it
conflicts with my sense of morality and
my ideology that's the human element I'm
talking about this guy has none of them
he's just a piece of [ __ ]
that's it I'm down with having a
misogynistic deck of a villain but you
got to give me something else something
to sink my teeth into for his motivation
it's not a thing he has it's just it's
all he is a 2z h stands for absolute
misogynistic dick B stands for [ __ ] ass
misogynistic dick
C stands for [ __ ] of a misogynistic dick
all the way to Z and I'm prattling on
about the villain but it was a huge
dynamic in the movie I feel like they
took what started out as a good villain
and sacrificed him on the altar of the
movies message agenda whatever you want
to call it but in all fairness
for this movie and what the movies
trying to do what its going for its
message agenda whatever you want to call
it it works in this movie for that so
whether or not you'll like that or don't
know that's just that's up to you this
is the epitome of a movie that will
thrive on his rewatch ability factor in
the end I'd rather watch Shazam Aquaman
Wonder Woman I'd rather watch any of
those before I watch this again as much
as I love Margot Robbie in this movie I
really liked Mary Elizabeth Winstead is
Huntress because I I really love her
anyway really enjoyed some of the action
and the group dynamic this is one of
those movies that's either going to hit
you or you're not gonna feel that if you
don't feel that I questioned whether or
not you'll really enjoy the movie like
if there's enough for you to sink your
teeth into I mean The Critic sitting
next to me I know her talk to her at
every one of the screenings she was
loving it having a great time I was
there like well it's fine and I walked
out of this movie going the action
sequences were fun in fact I got the
medicine this movie probably be a better
time not drunk but you know yeah now
it's a party put your Dare shirt down
all right so birds of prey have you seen
it what did you think about it are you a
black mask fan did they do him justice
in this movie you like not my black tag
not my black mask whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]